President Trump says preparations are
proceeding for his summit with North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un
correspondent rich Edson is live tonight
at the State Department with the latest
on all this good evening which I could
evening bredren as we await for more
information about these North Korean
discussions perhaps to come out of this
news conference Mike Pompeo is waiting
for his confirmation as the Secretary of
State designate out of the US Senate
that something Republicans are pushing
Democrats to do and do soon CIA director
Mike Pompeo returned this month from the
most important diplomatic mission of the
Trump presidency and now President Trump
is publicly leaning on one Senate
Republican in public opposition to
Pompey hos nomination as Secretary of
State Senator Paul says he spoke with
the president and out of respect for him
agreed to meet with the compound it
would be a big deal for me to change my
position on him in a conference call
with reporters this afternoon Arkansas
Republican Senator Tom cotton predicted
the Senate would confirm Pompeo next
week he argues it would send a very bad
sign ahead of the president's summit
with kim jeong-hoon
if Senate Democrats rejected his
confirmation Republicans say they're
targeting Senate Democrats from
Republican leaning states and argue
Pompeo with his meeting in North Korea
with Kim jong-un is already leading
American diplomacy speaking for the
president essentially acting as
Secretary of State
Democrats say they worry Pompeo won't
check the president's worst instincts it
makes me more concerned not less that
director Pompeo be someone who is able
to adequately represent the president
and stand up to him at times when he
makes abrupt and unwarranted changes in
direction at his confirmation hearing
last week Pompeyo had already met with
the North Korean dictator a week and a
half earlier no one is under any
illusions that we will we will reach a
comprehensive agreement through the
president's meeting but to enable to set
out to set up the conditions that would
be acceptable to each side for the two
leaders who will ultimately make the
decision about whether such an agreement
can be achieved and during the
confirmation hearing Pompeo also refused
to rule out a military strike against
North Korea though
stress there is a lot of diplomacy left
to explore with kim jeong-hoon he also
stressed the u.s. is not looking to
overthrow him what is unknown about the
president's summit with kim jong hoon is
where when and what kim jeong-hoon may
be willing to surrender and what the
United States is willing to give and
return Brett Richardson live at the
State Department rich thanks